it's a new year and a new month which
means a new batch of free PlayStation
plus games are available to claim right
now these freebies include Star Wars
Jedi fall in order Fallout 76 and Axiom
Verge 2. Star Wars Jedi Fallen order is
a 2019 game that follows the events
after Star Wars episode 3 Revenge of the
Sith the game revolves around Jedi
Padawan calcestus who survived the purge
of that film and is on a mission to
fight back against the empire this
freebie is perfect for people who want
to catch up before the March release of
the sequel Jedi Survivor as well as
those who just want to refresher when I
first played Fallen order I got a little
tripped up by the combat I had never
played a souls-like type game but now
that Elden ring has taught me the virtue
of patience I've been thinking about
going back to fall in order to try to be
more of a badass Jedi without lowering
the difficulty the second game is
Fallout 76 the latest in the
long-running Fallout series The entirely
online game still has an active
Community employers can choose to go it
alone or team up with others at launch
76 was met with scrutiny over technical
issues and the online multiplayer format
but the game has attracted a passionate
player base over the years and it's
worth checking out the final game is
Axiom Verge 2 a metroidvania sequel to
the first Axiom Verge the game follows a
researcher who gets transported to an
alien world there's a heavy emphasis on
exploration in diverse biomes and
platform puzzles you'll have the rest of
January to claim all three of these
games but honestly why wait you can even
claim them right now on your phone if
you're like not next to your Playstation
but speaking of waiting maybe I should
have held off buying an OLED switch I
say this because it seems like the next
limited edition Nintendo switch OLED
console may have leaked according to
Insider gaming photos of a Legend of
Zelda tears of the Kingdom themed
console first surfaced on the gaming
Message Board site family boards before
making the rounds on Reddit and other
social media platforms if confirmed the
tears of the Kingdom OLED motto would be
the latest limited edition console tied
to a major release a list which includes
the Pokemon scarlet and violet model
that released on November 4th and the
Splatoon 3 Model that released on August
26th those previous limited consoles did
not come bundled with their respective
games and it is unclear if this alleged
Zelda console will follow suit and in
other Nintendo leak news a new tease
popped up over the holidays pointing to
a possible Metroid Prime announcement
soon though keep in mind there have been
rumors about a remastered Trilogy for
years now so don't get your hopes too
high take this info with a grain of salt
a gaming leaks and rumors moderator
posted that a verified leaker direct
message them quote do you think everyone
is primed and ready Reddit user
spheromancer added that this same person
teased The Legend of Zelda tears of the
Kingdom title before it was officially
announced now this cryptic message could
go in a couple of different directions
for starters Metroid Prime 4 was
announced over five years ago and it's
been silent since developer Retro
Studios overtook development in early
2019. there also have been rumors for
years of a remastered Metroid Prime
Trilogy in fact gamespot's sister site
Giant Bomb reported that the original
Metroid Prime was planned to release on
Nintendo switch this past holiday season
to coincide with the game's 20th
anniversary Insider gaming speculates
that a Nintendo Direct could be on the
horizon especially considering the Zelda
OLED switch model leak but nothing
official has been announced by Nintendo
now hit the comment section let me know
what you got into over the holiday
season and if you got any cool gifts my
wife got me an espresso machine so I'm
pretty caffeinated right now I'll see
you tomorrow
foreign